You can sit here.
I'm going to do my own performance.
So I should speak while I'm like...
Where it felt in the zone or otherwise just rub it.
Okay.
So we're going to use this piece of art to play in pause.
So we'll go backwards when we proceed forwards,
but if you want to, we'll continue commentating.
That's pause.
Okay.
It looks like we're just stretching here.
Should I skip ahead?
Should I start again?
We're just going to wait.
You may just have to wait.
Okay.
I'm just doing 90-90s here to stretch,
warm up my hips.
Wow.
Okay.
You can relax a little bit, Victor.
Just maybe close your eyes.
Yeah.
Wait for the video.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right, I'm stirring the poonsae now.
This was the first time practicing it since at least the summer.
On the way to UBC on the bus ride,
I was watching the video,
on YouTube, just making sure I wouldn't mess up
any of the steps.
And here I'm supposed to bow in.
I think I forget to do that.
Okay.
I do all the steps pretty smoothly.
But I'm a lot less rigid than I need to be at the end.
I kind of sway a little bit after each movement.
Here I kind of...
My foot position is wrong.
The front foot is supposed to be facing forwards
and the other one is more to the back.
But I didn't make any major mistakes.
Like, I was afraid I would.
That's not a very good...
Shouldn't be.
Oh.
, oh.
Wait.
I'll tell you later.
So now it's easier to Be careful.
Not...
I mean, you're just looking for more information on how you're scoring.
So as you can see, your pattern is scored better.
Yeah.
based on the number 10.
So out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation on this side.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy, it's actually scored from a four.
So from the number four,
you're actually marked during your presentation
of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make,
whether if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of a 0.1.
If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know
about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So say we're doing a outer block.
If it's not your shoulder height,
maybe it's a little bit lower,
or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake.
So that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be,
you're supposed to do it
out of block in the pattern,
but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead.
So that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake,
let's say pattern one, for example,
there's 20 steps.
It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes
in the 20 patterns, sorry, the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one being,
it needs to be absolutely perfect
to get, to not get a deduction
on 0.1.
So it's not uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps
and you made, let's say, 15 mistakes.
So what would that be?
So we'll leave that there on this side
and we'll come back and we'll just calculate
what you got at the end.
So a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left,
but you turn to the right, that would be a major mistake.
So obviously we do wanna try
and avoid any of these major mistakes.
So after we've done our pattern, that's why.
That's when we move on to the presentation side.
So the presentation, as you can see,
it's from a score of six.
This six is actually split up into three parts.
So we have one, two, three here.
So with this one, for a score of two,
is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of two.
And your expression, sorry,
I'm just gonna get you to begin the video
because there is that warmup section that we want.
You don't need to narrate or score that.
So when it looks like you're about to start,
you do wanna also watch.
You can just pause it there.
Don't worry about anything.
You can watch it later.
Okay, thanks.
Energy is also scored out at two as well.
So we'll start off with the power and speed.
So with this one, whether it's your blocks,
your kicks, your strikes.